car nous croyons bégonias rigoler ce que
j'ai oublié de vous dire et quoi ils et
19h44 j'ai un truc de ouf mais de ouf à
vous dire j'ai bien dit penser alors il
ya quelqu'un là quelqu'un qui m'a dit il
ya quelqu'un une star internationale qui
me harcèle sexuellement deux d'or t'es
continuellement amis on est vraiment je
te jure on t'aime beaucoup ne néglige
pas à te faire mal et plutôt où tu sais
non mamie ça me fait très plaisir tu dis
ça parce que tu me vois toujours plus
beau que je me suis tu te trompes mami
est une star internationale qui me
harcèle via son agent
pour que je vienne à son concert arrêt
mais vraiment les appels de partout
internationale elle veut que je vienne
avec eux je vais à une femme
elle veut que je vienne el botcho vierge
elle veut que je viens en laye sanaryens
probable vous êtes sûr que vous avez
bien qu'on se sépare en pro a elle a un
agent français à cap-pelé tout mon
entourage que vous fassiez quoi qu'il
lui a dit pour que je vienne assister à
son concert qu'il a rencontré ensuite
dans les loges plus sûre vous ne doit
pas en pire à mon avis non quoi on peut
dire un non et c'est pas la ravissante
hepburn là qu'étaient venus qui vous
dévorer des yeux à la jambe non alors
elle m'a marveaux d'accession instable
pour savoir comment j'allais pas non pas
toi l'ami gégé
voilà ça n'avait elle est jeune oui je
sais qui c'est c'est une très grande
star
je sais qu american est jeune je n'ai
pas pas de plus vous en dit plus à l'est
à rien a grandi non non mais c'est pas
aussi connu que ça ah oui c'était facile
et non céline due au redoux
c'est une douche
je suis le pape dieye nous ont touchés
par ces du jour merci
15h10 qu'individu non c'est pas car des
8es pas car tu sais pas car des beatles
à ses clients des jeannet jean-michel
michèle torr michel torres est non c'est
pas aussi non rihanna non non non non
pourquoi non c'est trouver qui est en
concert en france
ah oui mais à cette prochaine bas cette
semaine
d'ailleurs la formation des salariés je
vous avais dit oui taylor swift
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aziz urgent de sortir je vais vous lire
le mail je vais me lire le mail et
d'argent ou d'or
taylor swift l'agent de taylor swift
vous a contacté mais c'est pas vraiment
d'acteurs non je vous raconte je reçois
un mail
oui est ce que on aimerait savoir est-ce
que cyril va venir au concert de taylor
swift et qu'est ce que ça peut lui fit
pas répondait lonard je n'ai pas répondu
là aujourd'hui on a appelé mon avocat un
qui le connaissaient ravaux lui dire on
veut vraiment savoir si cyril va venir
voir taylor swift la semaine prochaine
elle voulait rien savoir mais en fait
nous emmener tous et là pour le coup
elle n'a pas envie de vous voir pour
vous pour moi qu'ils ont tardé donc je
vous le dis c'est lundi je vais faire
les missions et après d'après ce que je
lis je ne pourrais pas assister au
concert mais je lui ai dit j'irai voir
c'est alors vous allez rencontrer leur
souffle dans sa loge faut le dire voilà
bourgeois pour qu'on échange un petit
peu sur les relations vous avez bossé de
grève c'est l'anglais un peu pour moi et
pour l'occasion taylor swift pour lui
faire plaisir
j'irai la chercher en suzuki swift hoxha
je viens téléspectateurs tanner quoi une
balle je vous le jure que c'est vrai et
donc j'ai dit voilà que j'irai
certainement la rencontre et après et
voilà et je vous dis je vous laisse vous
retrouve le match
elle veut passer la night avec toi tu
dis oui bah oui où il est pas là dedans
mais oui mais oui mais oui on passa parc
d'attractions non mais oh
elle vous plaît je le refuse aussi les
rats mission de cellartis fut jamais si
shell qui vend le plus de disques et
c'est le plus influent dans tout le la
suite et la fin profiter allez-y c'est à
dire quoi ba est vraiment elle est
vraiment joli nom mais elle est pas la
nommer la jam unique qui vous lit mais
pas une invitation comme ça en loge cap
et les deux pas du tout il y aura plein
de monde ne sera pas que tous les deux
pendant ces artistes canadiens qui sont
les sardines elle a dû se renseigner et
demandé qui était le qu'était la nuit
l'animateur c'est ce qu'à votre
prestation lundi
ah oui quand vous avez chanté queen je
suis un peut-être mais voilà alors je
vous en dirai plus sur cette affaire
autour de leur tâche et se voit là moi
je vais vous dire j'ai envie de parler
avec elle d'artistes artistes le
compositeur un compositeur prévoir un
sujet de conversation bien sûr on doit
montrer lui vos cuisses un crois
vraiment tu vas les bras
tu me remettre mais sans déconner elle
peut passer la nuit avec vous accepté
parce que la taylor is rich
oh non
[Rires]